[Applause]
[Applause]
yes
here we are once again happy wednesday
everyone
we no longer call it hump day
after that chat with human resources
but what a treat to have you here
the wonderful patient brown is back look
at her huh
security's supposed to stop her at the
door
but who could say no to that smile
so is our friend from alaska jamie lisao
sarah palin once said at jamie's career
i can't see it from my house
or anybody else's
so what was one of the most repeated
phrases in the last few years to
describe america
other than china's [ __ ]
how about polarized every expert in
media crank claims we are at each
other's throats and maybe it's true if
you're on a new york city subway or
worse married to this
but
but for the most part if you go to the
gym the supermarket or the park anywhere
jamie lissau sleeps
you'll see people getting along
americans pretty much get by on the
universal belief leave me alone unless i
ask for help and i will do the same you
know it's the same words cat says to her
tapeworm
[Laughter]
we know your secret
so why the perception that we hate each
other well the belief comes from the top
of a dung pile 50 feet high
the press which is the least popular
thing since ben and jerry's chunks of
squirrel ice cream
they churn out conflict to drive ratings
and keep the population anxious so they
seek out even more conflict they can
take a mass shooting and make it last
for weeks creating copycat mass
shootings that feel less like news and
more like a 10-part mini-series they can
take a very confusing veterans bill and
turn it into a fight between people who
love veterans and people who want them
to die
of course it's false but entertaining as
every story becomes a fight between two
idea prisons and no one bothers to read
the bill including me
and now a new study from the university
of pennsylvania finds that cable news is
more polarized today than in the last 10
years
how is that even possible right
members of the crips and bloods look at
us and go geez chill out my brothers
[Laughter]
you do they do
i'm tight with them
which means it's time for
greg's quiz
letter for your convenience
[Music]
so this polarization in the media the
researchers claimed that it really
exploded after a
the election of donald trump
b
the election of donald trump
see all of the above
d
eggs
apparently you know the answer
researchers examined guests who appeared
on a channel and rated them on a bias
scale based on their political beliefs
or contributions and their findings well
get this that our guests are way more
attractive
yeah
no surprise i mean compare and contrast
right
hard to believe they're brothers
actually it's father son
i don't know what i'm saying but they
didn't publish that information so i'm
just guessing but they found that fox
news leaned more conservative
i know you're all in shock right now huh
let's roll tape of one of our faithful
viewers hearing this
oh there he goes
oh my goodness
that was the best trick ever
yeah stop the presses wait grandma dig
up gramps tell mike lindell to put down
as my pillow
it turns out we aren't liberals ah
but they also found that msnbc and cnn
are much more left-wing than ever with
cnn really going bonkers surpassing the
usually far nuttier msnbc
and this move became way more pronounced
after trump won
well that's great detective work guys
this is like an episode of the dumbest
forensic files
how did how did you piece this
complicated puzzle together
was it when trump's win left the media
crying like strippers when hunter's
credit card
was declined
i was shocked by that photo
now let's be clear when they say network
split from one another after the
election that's bs we were far from
being on the same page
prior to trump
they always presented a uniformly
left-wing opinion no matter what we did
and the polarization wasn't about
competing narratives it was about a
single pole the libs having to now
compete against the new poll us
and the new poll that simply represented
opinions of viewers instead of anchors
they didn't like that they were so used
to telling people what to think that
they forgot how to listen and then they
forgot how to think which is why we
pounded them like the end of a ketchup
bottle
which makes it harder to remove
anyway to discover this now is idiotic
and also they're comparing apples to
oranges or rather apples to don lemons
a little wordplay there p.a.b
i bet you missed some of that huh
they compared our opinion folks to their
anchors
like anderson cooper
don't they see how off that is you know
tucker does commentary you know that i
do commentary and brett hemmer and that
other guy on the weekends they do news
you know when they aren't doing butt
loads of ketamine
how do you think they're so perky at
that hour
but cnn acts as though what they spew is
news when it's almost 90 commentary
that's how arrogant they are they really
believe that even their opinion is fact
but they never say commentary that would
require self-awareness and the closest
they came to that was chris cuomo oiling
up his own
i pecs doing it for him
but this new research is valuable
because it shows you where the division
is coming from the news divisions it's
not us we just want everyone to have a
good time after all i'm not just the
king of late night i'm the rodney king
of late night
right
and what did he say
why can't we all just get along
so admits all this divisive chaos don't
forget it ain't us
like long coved it's long trump
derangement syndrome and until they come
up with a vaccine for that it's gonna
get worse
[Applause]
his act has audiences praying for a
drone strike actor comedian and writer
jamie lisa
so sweet candy is worried she'll give it
cavities for fox news anchor and author
of the great book write your own story
how i took control by letting go p-a-b-a
[Applause]
she's so thin you can use her as a
bookmark fox news contributor catch him
and since third grade he's permanently
banned from pony rides my massive
sidekick in the nwa world health
champion
so p.a.p welcome back how's your book
doing is it doing okay it's doing great
since the last time i was here
especially i say that you know we should
do is everybody watching go into
wherever just google patty and brown and
write your own story and order the book
and let's see where it moves by tomorrow
morning huh isn't that fun something to
do that's a great idea it is a great
idea you're welcome
so you were before you know you were
once a top class news anchor how has the
news changed since you've left
it
i don't want to say it's gotten more
polarized because i really think it has
always been polarized yes but i do agree
that the trump derangement syndrome i
love the expression saying it's like
long covid it continues even after he's
gone although you know he's not
completely gone no
but studies like this i have to say the
university of pennsylvania i give them
credit for trying but they're all
worthless the way they conducted this
was by saying we're going to look at the
perceived biases of the guests who
appear on these shows yes and then we're
going to decide and they're not they
said specifically we're not looking at
the anchors just the guests and they're
going to base their conclusions on
people's perception of whether things
are more biased based on our perceptions
of the guests that they put on the shows
yeah you know it's it's it's nonsense i
tell you p-a-b
nonsense and speaking of nonsense
hello jamie
[Laughter]
i'm under the impression you still get
news in alaska
correct
yeah i know a lot about this
polarization uh almost all the bears in
alaska are polarized
[Applause]
nice i'll show myself out
i love it
it's uh it's getting crazy it is wild
though how the other cable networks will
be so contrarian or like remember you
came out with a high ratings and they
were like we're going the other way with
it
um
you know
you know what really got me i i get i've
gotten frustrated a lot this year but
what really got me was is how like how
like biased it was was the changing of
the word the definition of recession
that like really bothered me you can't
just
change
what words mean you know like how far is
this gonna go they're gonna be like oh
you know when biden falls down the
stairs they're gonna be like oh we're
gonna call it learning parkour
or uh
when he has dementia they're gonna be
like he always has a fresh take
[Laughter]
yes
any other words that's kind of that's it
that's it all right i didn't want to
leave you know if i got free money on
the table i'm going to take it that's
the way i look at it tyrus in reality
are people really that polarized
yeah but i want to stick with him it's
reduced feelings wouldn't it be cool if
like child support was just a feeling
[Laughter]
yes
let's just let's not be so quick
just you know it's it's feeling not
the feeling in your heart while your
money's stolen from you um this is like
this encounter group you get two guys
that does
you're not divorced
[Applause]
no no what are you talking about
damn it man yeah you're polarized
you've been polarized since polaroid
of course
it's not even that it's it's none of
that it's greed it has nothing to do
with anything else
president trump made you rich
if you went after him he made more
thousand errors because he couldn't
manage their money right he made more
thousand errors on cnn they got book
deals they got their own shows and it's
just the and the problem they're going
to sue him
because
he got them to the dance and then when
he left they weren't able to keep
singing so it's his fault so they're
going to always need him and go after
him because he made them relevant right
and they mistake that with their own
talent their own journalism
when is the last time anyone even if
acosta showed up
outside here people would just walk
around him no one would boom anymore no
one would be like man what you said last
week about
no because the president left and when
he was on the microphone it was we we've
been there
but
that's what happens when akasa gets on
the mic uncomfortable silence
see
see i got nervous see the difference
yeah i got very trump out yeah acosta it
goes back to being a crime yeah that's
the name of my new netflix special
uncomfortable silence
[Laughter]
kat what's your take on this study
i yeah i think that also social media
has a lot to do with it because
now if you work at a specific place
people will sort of assume that means
certain things about you and attack you
based on that or if you say something
that may not be what's you know
ideologically expected of you based on
whatever the partisan slan is for the
network you work for you'll actually see
people get mad at you about it even when
it's not that many people it can feel
like a ton of people which is why i try
not to look but like last week when i
was talking about voting third party
there was a few people that were mad
they're like i'm sick of cat and it's
like how do you think i feel
don't complain to the person who has the
problem worse than you i can't get away
from me ever
uh but i it can mo you know motivate
people to stay in line with those things
i think that seeing things on social
media is not any of anything that any of
us should ever be seeing i think it's
made this problem a lot worse you're
probably right and also i think i am no
yeah i think you are i feel you are yeah
filling up more buckets these days you
got to fill up everything that's what it
is in the good old days we wouldn't have
this many buckets but this bucket rules
right huh
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else